the talk about porn cuz I'm sure that
not going anywhere on the internet
Arizona's Republican Governor Jan Brewer
you know jan Brewer
she signed a law this week cracking down
on revenge porn
classifying it as a sex offender a
course revenge porn is when
you post photos or videos usually have
an accent yours without their consent
there's a budget state that have this
would get a little info on law
Arizona's strict new law makes revenge
pointer
Belletti establishing an initial 18
months in prison
or two and a half years in prison if the
person in the image can easily be
identified
it will apply to any photographs
videotape film or digital recording a
person
and it makes it a crime to disclose
display distribute publish
advertise or offer these photos or
videos
I this seems all good to me I usually
don't agree with jan Brewer
but they seemed pretty good is there
anything wrong with this kinda law and
did we really just need this
because a that was my question like why
do we have to say they are not allowed
to post
revealing photos up your act on the
Internet like better be albeit should be
I
do that are no people sometimes have a
bad major I'm yeah I think an RA
yeah I mean it's ridiculous that the
even had to be fed like don't
be an asshole don't break don't murder
people don't post pictures people on the
internet for everyone to see and pay
their privacy like that
common sense whether the original
eleventh commandment thou shalt not pose
for pictures and movies
everybody that level up lot a yeah
all good here ordered openly I mean
obviously this
needs to be legislated because a people
will argue that this is a violation of
free speech and that they should have
the right to
be able to say this and if there's
something in their possession especially
you know it get complicated when
somebody takes felt the and the
interesting thing is that some of these
revenge y mas actually
don't apply to you self record at the
inn in Arizona they do but in rather
stay to love them don't apply to like
self recorded images which I think
is a new want that shouldn't be written
into the law
but that's where I think the legality
gets confusing because I took a picture
myself naked and gave it to you and that
this is now your property
he does although then yeah it's our
relationship yeah that's good
don't gotta okay well aa work already a
at though if I did that you should
you know you might be able to argue that
it now your property and you can do
whatever you want with it
on now i'm for it yeah I'm partly
there's no waiver signed
there are no relief there if they were
waiver signed this
revenge porn I would not apply right if
that actually
not a terrible idea like have an app
where you're gonna send all your new did
you have to actually Alex Tanguay
saying I the reduction of all the time
if i film you on the street during an
interview in you don't want your face on
camera
you can choose not to sign the release
and then after blur your face that out
yeah
the fact that the there you know private
experiences
that people will ultimately I think I
think that kind of the interesting thing
about this law
it's sort of like the separation between
a typical violent crime and a hate crime
because it motivated by something that's
really specific and really dark and
kinda violent and
vengeful and because I've that direct
motivation
a I think the penalty should be stronger
because the actual
act is is the
I honestly like what is your protection
that act like what can you argue in a
courtroom
right that the oh yeah I did write in
good faith and
in town at the pike Senate that picture
to all my friends
good yeah I just wanted to promote
lewdness up this other guy with gray
up his part around here that we got all
this technology so fast
you know any like the Internet is all
really for for our purposes it's like 20
years old you know it's not that long
ago that it was all dial
and we got all of this stuff webcams and
phone cameras in snapchat we got it also
passed
that everybody started doing all this
crazy stuff and now it's like we'd need
these laws to control us because
otherwise
it's just endless right yeah people are
people not the brightest soldiers do
whatever they can with what they have I
mean
it's not the technology's fault though I
mean we have a bunch of things our
disposal of your choice to
to be a jerk with it so now at the
technology's fault but definitely people
are going
all the crazy and have to make laws like
this where short-sighted as a society
that's part of the problem is that
people make decisions that seem good in
the moment
and they don't think about the
ramifications down the line and it's
also
difficult because there's no legislation
in place protecting
miners heard stress and so yeah we are
you in the country all the time about
the legal drinking age the legal driving
it look at what point are you
responsible enough to operate heavy
machinery or
you know at take a substance that
psychotropic
and so yeah at what point are you
responsible enough to
have at camera and the ability to upload
any picture that you take onto the
internet it's difficult when you're
young person
it even harder to think about the
downstream ramifications and their
biological reason for that
that part of your brain isn't well
developed though and we're also not
socialized to have that kinda
responsibility at that age that that's
where
things get difficult that's why I think
it is so important to have legislation
like this
yeah I am totally on board we were all
in agreement there